big fight announcement yeah tank Davis
and now April 22nd are you nervous no no
really no too undefeateds too undefeated
not even Alex nervousness wow it is a
big it's the biggest fight in my life I
just don't feel nervous oh it's one of
the biggest fights of I mean probably in
a hot second next like three years right
yeah I mean last five years this this
fight has been like rumbling and rumors
and was supposed to happen and finally
you know once the fighters and that's it
you know it's real it's like it's an
insane fight so Javonte Davis I think
was he 27-0
I think 25 Knockouts but he's like show
times like he's he's the main guy
pay-per-view guy and he's a knockout
artist and then you know Ryan is this
young knockout artist undefeated
obviously
you know we're both knockout Fighters uh
I wield this into existence you know I
was uh I was so determined to make this
fight happen so like I'm just so happy
it's finally here that's why I'm not
nervous about it because I kind of
manifest I wanted it more than anything
in my life